le lion de belfort est malade depuis un
an il est caché dans une cage
inesthétique au grand mécontentement des
touristes le lion de belfort a été
réalisée par le sculpteur bartholdi de
colmar 2875 1881 il a été construit en
dhr et des vosges c'est le club alpin
français qui en 1886 a été chargé par le
sculpteur lui même d'assurer la gestion
du monument
ce monument a été nettoyée à plusieurs
reprises au cours des années 1935 et des
années 1950 et actuellement il est en
réfection
l'afer est elle rentable pour le club
alpin français
en principe il y à des bénéfices
réalisés plus ou moins importants chaque
année
ses bénéfices sont utilisés par la
section de belfort du club alpin
français d'abord à l'entretien des
monuments à la rémunération du gardien
et à l'équipement sportif et touristique
de la région
monsieur clair vous représenter
l'association départementale du tourisme
cette maladie du lion porte tel
préjudice mme à ce tourisme
assurément oui tant sur le plan
financier que sur le plan publicitaire
car nous pouvons dire que chaque année
environ 100 mille touristes
venez visiter le lion de belfort or
depuis qu'il est en réparation depuis
qu'il est caché par les échafaudages
ce nombre est beaucoup plus restreint eu
en 63 combien de touristes par rapport à
62 par exemple lors que le lieu n'était
pas en cours en cage
eh bien nous pouvons dire qu'en 1962 il
y a eu environ ce sont des chiffres
toujours approximatif parce qu'on ne
peut pas faire un contrôle très strict
de chaque entrée mais il y avait environ
entre 80 et 100 mille touristes et en 63
puisque les échafaudages où tu étais
placé début juillet juin juillet ou même
eh bien ces touristes le nom de ces
touristes est tomber beaucoup plus bas
nous pouvons dire qu'il ya eu environ 50
mille choristes
monsieur chic et vous êtes sculpteur des
beaux-arts voulez vous nous dire de quoi
souffre le lion de belfort
renault lui ont été attaqués par la
madoff par la maladie par l'otan plus
exactement alors les pierres arrive à
s'éroder et certaines ont besoin d'être
changée par le fait des intempéries
combien de pierre pensez vous devoir
changer bien pour l'instant d'où
procédant au décapage si bien que nous
mettons la pire à vif après un bon
nettoyage et ensuite nous pourrons
vraiment constater l'état des dégâts
vous avez usé beaucoup de bois ce
monsieur choqué l'uson surtout beaucoup
d'eau et de la brosse aussi puisqu'il
faut frotter et c'est surtout lockheed
élèves la crasse et qu'il a permis de se
diluer de s'en aller dans combien de
temps pensez-vous que le lion sera de
nouveau hors saccage mode ici quelques
d'ici un mois il sera entièrement
nettoyé quant aux réparations
elles seront fonction du temps matériel
de les exécuter c'est à dire peut-être
deux mois peut-être trois mois peut-être
davantage
merci de ce cycle